welcome to this lecture
on chemical curiosities
I'm gonna start with the liquid in this container
and I just pour some into this cylinder
since it's a nice
bright red color
let's see what happens
if I keep pouring
I think you can see every time I pour out the
liquid I seem to get a different color
so, in the dictionary
the word curious
is defined to mean something which is
puzzling or surprising or unexpected
and this demonstration might
seem rather puzzling at first
until we realize that the cylinders
were not empty at the start
each of them had a little speck of
chemical which reacted with the liquid
in this container
and it produced a color change and we'll look at
the chemistry of that in just a moment
let's have a look at the liquid in
these two beakers they are both colorless
let's see what happens when I
pour the liquid from this beaker
into this one
so again we see a color change it's turning
blue, the blue is getting darker
as i keep pouring
goes away again
thats also rather odd
it seems as if
a chemical reaction began
and produced the color change
and then it sort of changed its mind and went
backwards so did it go backwards did that chemical
reaction go backwards
so the chemistry of these demonstrations
is based on a simple idea which is that
every substance can be thought of is either an acid
or an alkali and if it's neither if
it's sort of in the middle
we say that it's neutral now we can use
certain substances to tell us whether a
material is acid or alkali
and probably one of the most famous
of these is called litmus
so litmus is a material which
is red in acid conditions
and its blue in alkali
conditions and there are lots of other
indicators. I normally used in this
experiment was called universal
indicator this has a range of different
colors it's red when things are strongly
acidic
in the middle where things are neutral its green
and in strongly alkaline conditions its
purple
and this experiment is based on an
indicator called thymolphthalein.
which is colorless
in acid and its blue
in alkaline conditions so these
cylinders had different amounts of acid
and alkaline in them producing the various
different colors
in this experiment the first beaker
had a mixture of thymolphthalein
and some acid and the second
Beaker had some alkali
and the key to this
is that when acid
mixes with alkali they
react to produce a salt
plus water so they are sort of opposites
they kind of cancel each other out
so as I started to
pour the liquid the
acid and final fehling from
here went into the alkali
the alkali quickly cancelled out the
acid so the final fehling is now
an alkaline solution that turns blue
but as I keep on pouring I'm
adding more and more acid
its neutralizing the alkali and
eventually this beaker becomes acid
as well
and the final fehling goes back to being
colorless so this reaction was not going
backwards it was just
the same reaction
all along we could ask is there a
chemical reaction that goes backwards
can chemical reactions go backwards at
all well it turns out to be a really
interesting question
and it's a question
that we gonna come back to several times
during the course of this lecture
but let me just show you
now an other example
of a reaction involving universal
indicator and it's this column of water
which has universal indicator and also a
little bit of sodium hydroxide which is
alkaline
and so it's turned it this sort of bluey
purple color I'm gonna add some acid
we should see it go through a
sequence of colors rather like these
now the particular acid that i'm gonna use
is acid that's going to be made
in the water from
carbon dioxide
so, in this beaker I have carbon
dioxide but it's frozen its at
-79 degrees centigrade it's become
a solid we call this dry ice
because when it warms up it doesn't melt to a
liquid it goes straight to the gas its
always dry
so when  I add the dry
ice to the water
it will react with the water to
form an acid called carbonic acid
thats the same stuff that's in fizzy drinks thats
what gives the the fizzy drinks that fizz
so let's see what happens
when I add this now
watch for the color changes
you should see that sequence
of different colors
okay
so in all the reactions we've seen
so far we mix two things together
it produced a chemical reaction
which gave rise to a color change
so let's have a look at
this flask. This flask has
a a colorless liquid in,
but if I shake the flask
it turns blue
that's a bit surprising because i didn't  seem
to be mixing two things together I was
i was just shaking up a single liquid
here is another flask it's a similar
idea this is a yellow liquid
if I shake it it turns red
if we gave it a really
good shake it turns green
there is something else rather surprising
about this as well. If we keep watching
the green is turning back to red
and if we look here the blue is
turning back to being colorless
infact the red will go back to being
yellow so it's going back through that
sequence of colors again
what's more I can even repeat it so If I
shake it again goes back to being blue
shake this again goes back
to being red and so on
if I wait it will go back so again it
looks as if we have a chemical reaction
that's going backwards but
the first mystery
is why do we have a color change at all
I didn't seem to be mixing two things
together
what we have to remember of course is
that this flask not only contains
water but it contains a gas
in fact the gas is just air
and air of course is a
chemical and when I shake
the flask I'm mixing
oxygen from the air
with the liquid and that's
producing the chemical reaction
so the next question is did this
chemical reaction then go backwards
as it fades from blue to colorless is it
a chemical reaction that"s going backwards
well unfortunately it is'nt because
what's happening is there's a second
chemical reaction taking place
this flask contains a dye
called methylene blue
when it reacts with oxygen it
goes from colorless to blue
but also in the flask there is some glucose
and that glucose slowly turns methylene
blue
from blue-color back to being
colorless this is the same idea
but with the different material
called indigo carmine
so again we didn't have a
chemical reaction going backwards
but we're gonna keep on looking for such
a reaction as we go through the lecture
so in the reactions we've seen so
far then we mix to things together
and we got a color change so let's
have a look at what happens when i mix
these two colorless liquid together so
first all this machine is just called a
magnetic stirrer
it just spins these little magnets and keeps
the liquid stirring it's just because i'm too
lazy to stand here
stir them by hand
so if a colorless liquid being stirred
i'm gonna add a second colorless liquid
and watch closely and see if you
can detect a color change
so keep watching
(Audience surprised)
okay  (Laughing)
very strange, very strange indeed, we mixed
these two chemicals and it seemed as if no
reaction took place
we just sat there for 10 seconds
and then suddenly it reacted
now that seems very odd very surprising but
what was really going on
what's really going on is that there
are actually two different chemical
reactions taking place
inside this beaker
the first reaction was
quite a slow reaction
it was a reaction between two
chemicals that produced Iodine
so imagine this reaction taking place
and slowly releasing iodine into the
solution
now the iodine would
appear as a sort of brown color
you can't see the iodine
because there's a second
chemical reaction taking place
there's a material in the solution
which is reacting very quickly with the iodine and
it's absorbing the iodine as soon as it's produced
and the secret to this is to
arrange that second material
is in short supply so the iodine is being produced slowly
is being mugged up by the second
material as soon as it's produced
when that second material runs out
after about 10 seconds or so
the next little piece of iodine to
be produced remains in solution
because the iodine is a bit hard to see
from the back of the room we've added
some starch
the iodine reacts with the starch and produces a
very dark blue color that appears to be
almost black okay so thats
called a clock reaction
so now you understand how that one
works. Have a look at this one
this involves three color
solutions so I poured out one
into there and I pour this
into here again watch closely
okay
so thats a sort of  two-stage clock
so i leave you to think about how
that one might be working so in
the reactions we've seen so far then
we mix chemicals together and we know that a
reaction has taken place because we had
a change of color
but there are lots of other ways that a
chemical reaction can show up
and one way is called a change of state so the state of something
just means whether it's a solid or
liquid or gas so something turns to a solid
to liquid or from a
gas to the solid then it's changed state
so we show you an example
of a chemical reaction that involves a change of state so
we will use these two liquids i have a  red
liquid and a colorless liquid
what I'm going to
do is to pour the
colorless liquid onto the
red liquid very carefully
and try to make two layers
so what I want to happen is for the
colorless liquid to be floating
on top of the red liquid in
in separate layers that they don't
mix so that's worked quite well
so what i've got now is one liquid
floating on top of another
and where they meets they undergo
a chemical reaction
and they're actually making a solid
a solid material is  formed
where the two liquids
meets what I can do is to
fetch out some of this solid material
and as I pull it
out of the beaker
of course it allows the two
liquids to meet each other again
and so they react again to form more
of this solid so if I'm careful
so as I wind
I'm pulling up this material and it
allows the two liquids to meet again and it
forms more this material
and this substance that's being formed is
actually nylon so we're making nylon
as I speak and if I'mcareful
I'd be able to just keep on turning this
and making this long thread of nylon
atleast until we run out of solutions. Okay so that's an example of a chemical
reaction
that involves a change of state. So let's
have a look at another reaction
that involve a change of state and
for this i'd like a volunteer please ...
who would like to volunteer
you are very keen, common, lets have
a big hand for our
volunteer, you would like to stand
there, put those on
what's your name ? Dylan. Dylan, alright
you stand just there
we gonna do some chemistry we  gonna
make a solid alright I'm gonna start of with a
flask
that contains a solution
of silver nitrates
and I'm going to
add a little bit of
ammonia now when i add the ammonia
you see that it's forming
a sort of brown color
now keep on adding the
ammonia and then in a minute
brown color should disappear
that's disappeared isn't it
now what I'm going to do is to add
some sodium hydroxide
that's now formed a sort of very
dark brown almost black material
so now I'm going to add more ammonia
and again I'm going to add ammonia untill
the liquid goes back to being colorless
It takes a moment or two
there we go and then finally
I'm going to add some glucose
so there's the glucose
I'm gonna put the lid on
with a clip-on I'm gonna give it to you Dylan and I want you to hold that
and I want you to give it a really good shake that's
it really hard shake that's good
that's it keep shaking that's it
so what's happening inside this flask now is
there's a chemical reaction taking place
and it's forming a
solid and the actual material
that it's forming is silver
we're making pure silver metal
keep shaking
it takes about three quarters of an hour is
that okay (Audience laughing) ... it does actually take a minute
but the harder you shake the better it
works so keep shaking don't drop it.
okay so metal silver metal is
being formed an atom by atom
and you can see it's all going quite black
that's because very finely divided
silver is actually
black in color
what we're hoping is gonna happen
over the next minute or so
is that those particles of silver will start to stick to the walls
of the flask
and as they build up
we should see a silver metal in the form of a mirror
building up on the
inside of the flask and
you've all seen those sort of decorations
you get it in Christmas those spheres that are
shiny
and they are made using this chemical
reaction little balls of glass
and the inside is coated with
silver using this kind of chemistry
doing really well okay
so I have quick look
almost there keep going a little bit
longer so it looks a little bit dark
excellent
alright give it back to me
then right let me take the
clip off you take out the stopper
just wash that off and
I pour out the
remaining chemicals
and then I'm going to
rinse this out with
distilled water
and I'm going to add a second time
third time there we go
and just look at that one
let's dry this off and
then clip back on
and if you like to just
give that a little polish
if you'd like to hold it up by the neck that's
it and if we bring a camera in
and have a look at this and we've got a
lovely silver mirror there we go
ok what I'm gonna do is give that to you. Take  that to home
and you can go back to your seat,
lets have a hand for our volunteer
ok so that's an example
of a chemical reaction
the produces a change of state and I
want to show you another example of
a chemical reaction
again this is going to go from
being a liquid to being a solid
so in  this flask I have a solution
of sodium acetate and
this sodium acetate is a liquid as you can see, but it would very much like to be a solid
it would like to turn
into a crystal
but it needs a sort of an excuse
to get going and the excuse
is gonna be some little crystals
of solid sodium acetate
in this dish so watch what
happens if I pour the liquid
onto the crystals I think
you can see that the liquid
as soon as it touches the
crystals is turning into a solid
and with a bit of luck we can
make a sort of chemical sculpture
seems to be working
okay so that's a sort of
sodium acetate sculpture
now what we've learned is that this actually has a
practical application in this is the
practical application this is something called a hand warmer
and it's a plastic patch and it contains
exactly the same liquid as in this flask
this is a solution of sodium acetate
and it would like to turn into a
solid it would like to turn into a crystal
but it needs some excuse to
get going and the excuse
is this little metal
disc and if I just
flip this disc backwards and forwards
that should be enough just to start the
crystallization and
there it is and we can see the
liquid turning into a
solid as it does so
its actually getting warm
so it's actually giving off heat
and there it is it has turned entirely into
crystals it's become quite
warm in the process
and I can put that inside my glove
and keep my hands warm for
half an hour or so and then I can take
this and put it into boiling water for a
couple of minutes
the crystals will turn
back into a liquid
I can allow it to cool and that'll stay as
a liquid that will stay like that for weeks
or months
until I'm ready to use it again
we can use it thousands of times
okay so that's sodium acetate
it's a sort of chemical sculpture
I'm gonna show you now another way
to make a chemical sculpture and
chris has been preparing
this this beaker contains
a mixture of para nitro acetanilide
and sulfuric acid and chris
has been warming it up
and when it's hot enough
it will undergo a reaction in which
this liquid will turn into a solid
this makes quite a bit of smoke so we've got
this special hood that will suck away
the smoke from the reaction
here it goes
<Audience applauding>
okay so that's a chemical reactions
that involves a change of state
so we've seen lots of chemical reactions now
in this lecture we've seen reactions
that
produced color changes we've
seen reactions that produce
changes of States and we're asking
ourselves the question
could a chemical reaction go backwards
you may have seen several reactions that appear
to be going backwards
but when we understood them a
bit more carefully we realize no they
weren't going backwards
so we'd still like to understand whether
a chemical reaction could ever go
backwards
now to do that we first of all have
to ask why does a chemical reaction
happen at all
why the chemical reactions happen in the first place
but to understand that we're gonna
look at some very simple chemistry
and it's the combustion
of hydrogen so Chris
has filled a balloon
with hydrogen gas
and we're gonna set fire to the baloon
and what will happen is the hydrogen
will react with the oxygen in the air
and that will produce a small quantity
of water vapor and it will also
release some energy
okay so this is the reaction
of hydrogen with
the oxygen from the
air here we go
okay so can we just have a show of  hands
can you put your hand up if you enjoyed that
demonstration
its quite a few can you put your hand up
if you'd like to see a slightly bigger one
okay that's everybody
alright come on Chris
okay now the last
balloon may have quite a pop
this one is going to make an even
louder pop quite a loud bang in fact
I'm standing quite close to this so
I'm gonna wear my ear defenders
what you might like to do is to cover
your ears for this one because it could
be fairly loud
okay we'll bring down the lights
this is the reaction of hydrogen
with oxygen
so i think you would have
noticed in that reaction
that energy was released
clearly so we've got a lot of noise
we saw the flame we saw the lights I could feel the heat and
probably in the front row could as well
so energy was released in that
reaction so what's happening
is that the starting material
the hydrogen and oxygen
were in a state
of high energy and
as a result of the reaction they've
moved to a state of low energy now
the total energy in the world is always
conserved you can't create or destroy
energy
so that difference in energy was given
out is given out in the form of that bang
that's a
the heat and the light and the sound and
so on so maybe that's why chemical
reactions happen
may be chemical reactions happen because the
chemicals move from a state of high-energy
to a state of low energy and they
give out that difference of energy
so it's a bit like taking a ball and
putting it on a slope if you put a ball on a
slope
it rolls down hill from a state of high energy to a state of low
energy
so maybe that's how
chemical reactions work
if it is how chemical reactions work
then it's pretty obvious that a chemical
reaction
could never go backwards
because going backwards
would be like putting a ball on a
hill and having it decide to roll up hill
that's not gonna happen okay so
we'll keep that thought in mind
and we'll look at some other examples of
chemical reactions that give out energy
now we've seen energy being given out in
the form a bang we saw a little bit
light being given off there
in the form of that flame
and I want to show you reaction that
gives off a great deal of lights
it's the reaction of a rather special
element it's called phosphorous
and the word phosphorus comes from the Greek
it means that the giver or the bearer
of light so this is a reaction that will
give out a great deal of light so
we could just burn a little
bit of phosphorus on the
on the bench but we thought we'd do is to
scale this up and do this on the larger
scale we could
and so this is actually the largest
flask that you can buy in the UK
and so this is about as big
as as we can make it and
we're gonna burn quite a big
chunk of white phosphorus
inside this flask, and to make it burn really
well, we're gonna fill the flask with pure
oxygen
now in order to fill the flask
with pure oxygen we're going to use
liquid oxygen; and we're gonna
make the liquid oxygen
by starting from another
liquefied gas - liquid nitrogen
so in this vacuum
flask I have some
liquid nitrogen it's a, a colorless
liquid - it looks pretty much like water
but it's at a very low temperature.  It's at - 196 degrees centigrade
so just for a little bit of fun I thought
we'd see what happens if we take some
liquid nitrogen at -196 degrees centigrade
and pour it into some pretty
much boiling water okay
and and this is what happens
there's no real point in that it
was just for fun you understand
okay so this liquid nitrogen is extremely cold
and we can use it to cool down
oxygen gas so that it too
becomes a liquid
that's what Chris has been doing over here. So this cylinder contains oxygen gas
and Chris has been passing the
oxygen gas through a coil of copper
that sat inside some liquid nitrogen
and the oxygen has been turning
into liquid itself and so this
vacuum flask contains liquid oxygen
i just want to show you one interesting
thing about to about liquid oxygen
I'm going to pour it into this test tube
and
you may be able to see
that although the
the air the air contains one-fifth
oxygen; and the air of course is completely
transparent
and yet oxygen when it becomes a
liquid turns this lovely blue color
okay so we're going to use this
liquid oxygen then
to fill this flask with
oxygen.
So I'm going to pour this in
and we'll add a bit more for good
measure
should be enough
ok and so the oxygen the liquid oxygen
is warming up as it touches the flask
and it's evaporating it's turning into
oxygen gas
and as as it as it turns into a gas it's pushing the air
you can see the the fumes coming out
the top here is pushing the air
out of the flask and filling
the flask with oxygen
just to help that along a
bit just gonna swirl this around
okay you can see a little bit of
liquid oxygen there that lovely blue
color sloshing around in the bottom of
this
flask so that gradually evaporating and
that's filling the flask with pure
oxygen
of course we could have just
taken a hose from this cylinder
into the flask and fill it with oxygen
that way but I think this was more fun
okay while that last little bit
is evaporating the next thing we're going to do is to get some phosphorous
there are two kinds of phosphorus red
phosphorus and white phosphorous
this is white phosphorous; it's the more
reactive kind.  It's so reactive
that it actually reacts with the air if
you just leave it sitting on a
a bench it will actually catch fire after a few
minutes and so we store it under water
So I'm gonna fetch out this piece of
white phosphorous and we're going to put
it in a little spoon
that's suspended from
the lid of the flask
You can see the phosphorous is smoking already
as it comes into contact with the air
and
that will probably catch fire sometime in
the next few minutes but just to help it
along
I'm going to take a glass rod
and heat up the end of the rod
and then just touch that against the
phosphorous just to get things going
and as a as soon as the phosphorous
ignites we'll bring down the
lights what you'll see is
the reaction of phosphorus
burning in pure oxygen
you can see this lovely white light that's being given out
it's a very vigorous reaction
the flask is filling with
oxides of phosphorous
so thats white phosphorus
the bearer of light
okay so that's a chemical
reaction then which gives out
energy in the form of light, I'm going to
show you another reaction now which
gives out energy again in form of light but
also in the form of sound
this is a reaction between
a colorless gas
which is in this glass tube called
nitric oxide and a liquid
called carbon disulfide
so this is the carbon disulfide. I'm gonna
add some of this to the tube
and then we're gonna mix them together.
So Chris is going to mix the carbon disulfide with the
nitric oxide the carbon disulfide evaporates and
turns into a gas
we've got a little bit of water in the
tube just to help them mix and
when they're thoroughly mixed
we'll set fire to it
now this happens this reaction
happens reasonably quickly
so we'll just bring the
lights down first
So you've seen a couple reactions there that
involve effectively combustion
and combustion can give rise to
some very interesting chemistry
and for this I'm going to set fire
to a brand-new fifty-pound note
as an example of
combustion so let me
soak the fifty pound notes
in some flammable liquid
and then we'll set it on fire this
is a this is my fifty pound notes
its brand new, and there
it is on fire
the flames have gone out but the fifty
pound notes I'm pleased to say is
entirely intact.
I'm very pleased about that
Now the reason that the fifty-pound note
survived has to do with the choice of liquid
so this liquid was 50 percent
alcohol which is inflammable
and 50 percent water
and it was the water
that protected the fifty pound note - it
absorbs heat, and it stopped the note from burning
so really that's not too surprising
because we know that we use water
to put out fires the fire brigade
carry water with them, they have hoses
they use water for
fire extinguishing
So let's have a look at some different ways
of putting out fires I've got here
three
fire extinguishers based on different
kinds of Chemistry
Now it would be very surprising wouldn't it
if we could use a fire
extinguisher not to put out a fire
it to make a fire worse.  It would be really
surprising if we could use a fire
extinguisher to start a fire
okay let's look at the first
kinda fire extinguisher
so this is called a water fire
extinguisher it contains water
under pressure when you let extinguisher
off the water comes out at the hose
you soak the fire and you put the fire
out.  Now if I let that off in here it would just
flood the lecture theatre so we do
something else that's that's equivalent
from the point of view of Chemistry
and and that's to use a water
pistol so this water pistol
contains just ordinary tap
water I can pressurize it
and we can
you're careful or you're wishful
so this is just like that
water fire extinguisher
it squirts a jet of water so could we use this to start a fire
well for this I'd like
a volunteer please who would like to volunteer
you are very quick
lets give a hand for our volunteer please
and what's your name yeah
Ciara, right Ciara ifyou like to put on
these safety goggles these are special
safety goggles because they are tinted
nice trendy shades
all right and
what you are going to do is
to squirt the water pistol at the
little metal dish. Can you see
that on the little stand there
and that dish contains a
mixture of silver nitrate
and finally padded magnesium and if you
get a little bit of water to land on it
we'll see if that can
start a fire now because
this contains magnesium
is going to produce a very
bright light so my suggestion
my recommendation is that you
don't look directly at the dish
but instead you look to one side now you
do need to look at the dish because
you can hit it in the water
so that's we've given you these special
goggles all right so of you go see if you could
get a little bit water into that dish
well done but thank
you very much
okay so that was the first time a
fire extinguisher that's that's the
water-based
fire extinguisher so if you see a little
fire involving magnesium and silver
nitrate don't try to put it out
with that, this is the
next kinda fire extinguisher it has
got a carbon dioxide
fire extinguisher and it contains
liquid carbon dioxide
under very high pressure
so just I pull out the pin
and point the nozzle up
we'll just set this off
and okay
so you can see the liquid carbon
dioxide and a very high pressure
comes out through the nozzle it turns
into a gas now carbon dioxide is often
one of the main results of combustion
it's something light wood or paper is
burning
the carbon reacts with the oxygen in
the air to produce carbon dioxide
to the carbon dioxide is the
end product of combustion
that's why it is good for putting out fires
so we use the carbon dioxide fire
extinguisher
to smother a fire
exclude the air
and therefore exclude the oxygen
and then the fire goes at
to be a bit odd if using
a fire extinguisher like this would
actually make the fireworse rather than
better
well let's see what that
might look like
so
again we're going to use carbon
dioxide in a very concentrated form
in the form of solid
carbon dioxide or dry ice
which is something that we saw little
bit earlier in the lecture this is a
block
of dry ice and again
we are going to use magnesium
so I have some
magnesium metal here
and its gonna make a
little pile in a little
trough that we've cut inside
the block I'm going to
set fire to the magnesium
and once its on fire
chris is going to put the the
other half of the block on top
and then the magnesium will
be sort of trapped inside
and if we bring the light stand and you
can see the combustion is becoming more
vigorous
this is magnesium burning
in carbon dioxide it's not putting
the fire out it's actually supporting
combustion
giving out this beautiful light the white
smoke you see is magnesium oxide
this is the sort of stuff that's used
in the indigestion tablets that kind of thing
I would'nt recommend that for
dealing with indigestion
so the
magnesium combines with
the carbon dioxide
to make magnesium oxide
and carbon thank you
okay we have a third
kinda fire extinguisher
and that's this one this
is called a dry powder
fire extinguisher it contains
a powder this pressurized
when we set this off the
powder comes out of the hose
and we can squirt at the fire and put
the fire out now these are actually
extremely good
fire extinguishers you have an
extinguisher in your kitchen one in your
car
is probably a dry
powder extinguisher and
these extinguishes usually contain
something like sodium or potassium
carbonate
or sodium or potassium bicarbonate
they're very effective
extinguishers they are good for
dealing with all kinds of fire
and it would be very surprising if using the
powder out of one of those that actually
make combustion faster
on make it worse well
i have to say can
in this spoon we have a gram of
commercial gun powder
it's made from a mixture of three
ingredients saltpeter ( chemical name is potassium nitrate )
and that act's as a source of concentrated
oxygen we call that an oxidizer
it contains charcoal
which acts as the fuel
that burns in the oxygen released
by the potassium nitrate
and it contains sulfur and
the sulfur is there to
aid combustions make the gun powder burn more easily
what would happen if
we took gun powder
and instead of using charcoal
which is the main fuel
we use some of the powder from a
fire extinguisher so this seems
pretty odd we gonna take away the
main fuel from the Gunpowder
and we are gonna replace it with something
that's used in a fire extinguisher
we are gonna use potassium carbonate for this
so if we mix those three
things together that is
potassium nitrate potassium
carbonate and sulfur
we get something called yellow powder
and so in this spoon we have a gram
black powder and in this spoon
we have a gram of yellow powder
now what I'm gonna do is to heat up
these two spoons and
we'll see if there's a difference between
these two powders, so there's the
Gun powder
and this is the a yellow powder
now gunpowder when it burns in
the open doesn't make a bang
it just burns with the Puff in a little cloud
of smoke so we are not expecting the gun powder
to make a bang
yellow powder however
very probably will make  a
bang and it could be fairly loud
so sometime in the
next minute or so
there could be quite a loud bang you
might wish to cover your ears for this
now as the spoons heat up at some point
the gun powder will get hot enough
but it will ignite we'll see a puff of
smoke the other part is a little bit
different
inside that spoon the materials
are starting to melt
they're flowing together and
some chemistry is taking place
the chemical composition is actually
changing as a result of being warmed
up
and at some point that
new mixture of chemicals
should give rise to a little
explosion
and the gun powder
gives a beautiful smoke ring
okay so that's some of the science of
combustion and that's how the powde
the powder from a
dry powder fire extinguisher could
actually make combustion a little bit
worse
so if you remember one of
the questions that we're
asking in this lecture is whether a
chemical reaction can go backwards
I said this is a very interesting
question let me show you
a fascinating reaction so
in this beaker is
a colorless liquid
I'm going to add
a second colorless
liquid it remains colorless
I'm gonna add some
yellow liquid and
it turned orange and add a little bit of red liquid
and it goes sort of green color
kind of muddy color now in a minute
or so that muddy mess will fade away
we'd be able to see the color of the
solution what I want you to do with to
watch the color
of this solution as it changes now the rather interesting story behind this
reaction
was first discovered in
about 1951
by a russian chemist called Boris Belousov and
he was trying to study the way
citric acid
behaves in the human body and
so he was mixing various materials
together in a beaker
and he discovered some very interesting
color changes any particular
he discovered an oscillating chemical
reaction that is a chemical reaction
that went through a sequence of color
changes and then came back to the
starting point
you can see that muddy
color is fading
and we've now got
got a green solution the solution
is not gradually turning blue
remember that it started at
Green and it's turned blue
I Borissov tried to sum it
all by the late in chemical
reaction
sort of like a reaction
that goes backwards and
people thought that reaction's
didn't do that sort of thing
so you wrote this up and
he sent it off to the top
chemistry journal in Russia and the
editors looked at this and they rejected
the paper because they
said that couldn't happen
okay it's not turn from
blue to red and green
to do Reds so
missile had his paper rejected
3 send it to another journal
and they did the same thing they
rejected as well because they thought
democrats it just shouldn't
behave like this
must be something wrong so you got
pretty depressed about this if I got so
depressed that he gave
up being a scientist
a discovery was so difficult and
and about ten years later
a Stevens have chemistry
zabinski that since the
Russian student discovered
status of notes not stand up
to blues has turned grade
all rights so remember that sequence
a green for a little while then blew
that it went Reds them but
simply briefly now it screened
so that the tin CE discovered the
littles notes and he recreated
this experiment and he was able to is
published the conference in Vienna
and then the whole world near back
sittin' again quite a sensation
they've got very excited about
these kinds of reactions cases
gone back to play it is now turning back
to read we'll keep going through that
sequence of colors
so it seems as if we have a
reaction sorta goes back with
released it goes round in a cycle so
most people started to study these
reactions and they came
up with other kinds all
oscillating reactions 2012 show you
one that has quite a nice story to it
because
this is discovered not by
professional chemists the by
a couple earth schoolteachers and
their names were Briggs and Russia
and then working a high
school in San Francisco and
they were using the school
chemistry labs after hours
and they discovered a different
kind all oscillating reaction
so again I have a clear liquids
I had a second clear liquid
and a third clear
liquid that turns
amber to keep watching
turns blue radar late so there's a
little bit like the clock reaction
the same thing erection
something starts and I attained
at this time it doesn't stay
play is going clear again
so it's become clear
that's going back to amber to keep watching
actively work and turns to blue again
okay so those are two
oscillating chemical reactions
just seems as if we found a chemical
reaction the does actually go backwards
but really that isn't what's happening
it's not like a ball rolling downhill
and then change its mind
a rolling back up hill again
it's more like a ball
going down a so to the helix
it gets back to the same color
as when it started but it's not
really in the same condition
because some of the chemicals have
been used up we could watch these
oscillations happening
but after 10 or 20 minutes
they will come to a stop
and that's because the chemicals have
been used up so we haven't really found
reaction yet that can go backwards
so does that mean that of theory
of chemical reactions is
correct member of theory
is the chemical reactions
like a ball rolling downhill
the chemicals go from high-energy to
low-energy and they give that back
energy difference in the fall
people light or sound or whatever
well let's look at this reaction
this interaction between two powders
so in the beaker's some barium
hydroxide it's a white powder
I've got a block of wood I
was gonna put some water
on the surface the what makes a
puddle I'm gonna stand the beaker
in the puddle and then in
this peak and this flask
I have some ammonium
chloride I'm
at the ammonium chloride to
the the barium hydroxide
and I'm gonna stare
using this probe which
is attached to this the moment
that this digital thermometer
things in the temperature
there is about 20 degrees
let me start to mix the prior to us
together and we'll see what happens to
the temperature
so the temperatures falling
very quickly well below
10 degrees now
and they took it has just gone negative
this is now the low note the grace
so it's a -7 degrees so the
temperatures falling very rapidly
the other thing that's happened
is that it's turned from a solid
into a liquid does not come
with a slushie white liquid
the temperatures down to -15 degrees so
well below the freezing point of water
i remember i stupid in
little puddle of water
so what should have happened
is that water should a frozen
never got frozen it
to the block it would
so that's pretty strange
because that's the reaction
that didn't give an insanity
it's a reaction took in energy
it actually took in heat from the
surroundings and that's why the
surrounding such
as the thermometer
dropped in temperature
so that's a bit like
putting the ball on a slope and
seeing the ball roll up hill
but it shouldn't happen to
this array strange reaction
it means that all theory
of wine chemical reactions
happen isn't quite right or
at least it isn't complete
there's something else that's
missing so what's missing you know
theory all had chemistry happens went
to illustrate this with the little
computer game we got
here a hundred discs
and each disc is yellow
on one side it's red
on the other and the ball
down the right answer
side show see the proportion of this
coochie yellow now starts at the mall of
as Yellow and let's see what
happens when we run little
simulation so that a
hundred times a second
the computer is choosing
a desk and its deciding
either to keep it the same color or to
flip it over and you can see on the
right hand side
the proportion upgrade and yellow now we
started off with all the disks yellow
very quickly we've got to state
where about half of them Red
in about half the
yellow let's try again
at this time we can set them all to
read we can run the little simulation
they start of all rate
very quickly they come to
a state where about half as the
reading about half of the magellan
so me to say this is
the think that we
started the discs off in a very ordered
state they were all the same color
and as the simulation run
the level is disorder increased
it went from a and ordered
state two more random States
and this is such an important idea given
a special name we call the degree of
disorder
entropy we say the entropy
tends to increase with time
we start of the things recorded
and they became very disordered
and the reason this happens very simple
is because there's only one way for the
disturb your yellow
there are lots and lots and lots of ways
for the DS the beast the roughly half
yellow and of bread
and so it's just simply can sing
the number of different ways have
arranging these discs that causes the
dais to go from an ordered States
the disordered state now
you might think well
well hang on a moment
if we wait long enough
sooner or later by chance although
this will become yellow again
so the system would then have gone from
the disordered stay tuned ordered States
now you're absolutely right
you have to wait a long time
this is doing about a hundred flip to
second if we did a trillion flips the
second
you still have to wait longer
in the age of the universe
on average before you see
them or yellow again so it's
almost certain that the world will move
from an altered states to disordered
state
I've got a couple other
teenage boys and
their bedrooms provide a perfect
illustration of this at
if i tidy their bedrooms everything is
very or didn't come back the next day
is almost certain to be a highly
disordered state without input from me
it will never gain from being disordered
to being ordered so that's the idea
entropy
entry fee increases and that
can drive a chemical reaction
so let's think about a solid
in a solid the atoms or molecules
are arranged in nicely
rose they're very order in so
the crystal lattice in a liquid
the molecules can move around
not in fixed positions anymore
so this is a more
disordered state in a solid
and a gas is even more
disordered because the
atoms or molecules are free to move
around they can fill the container
so as we go from solid to
liquid to gas the entropy
all the disorder increases up sarra to
things that can drive chemical reactions
is the ball rolling downhill
effects the decrease in energy
all there is the
increase in entropy
the teenager bedroom
effect this reaction
is being driven by that increase
in entropy is gone from a solid
to a liquid and that increase
in entropy is so big
the overcomes the fact he actually
has two increase the energy
that reaction to happen that
reaction happens spontaneously
let's draws energy in from the
environment and cools its environment
and
that's why that reaction happens
so that means that we have two things
that can drive chemical reactions it's
not just the ball
rolling downhill
it's also the the the bedroom
effects and so perhaps
now that we have that deeper
understanding of Chemistry perhaps we
can I find
a chemical reaction
that goes backwards
well to help this find
this I'm going to
use the word curious in a different
sense we've used curious to the strange
or surprising or
unexpected the curious
can also refer to
desire2learn to curiosity I'm gonna
tell you a story about curiosity
in a a young chemist so
easily with ira rents in
and as an adult he became
very famous he founded the
chemistry department at John Hopkins
University and he discovered the first
official sweetener
let's call saccharine but
as a teenager he was
curious about chemistry and used
to do some little experiments
I'm good telly a story in his words
about an experiment which he performed
when he was a youngster now the
experiment involves the reaction between
copper
and nitric acid and so when we get to
the appropriate point in the story
I'm actually gonna show you their action
the reactions gonna happen in this flask
in this cylinder at the top
we have some nitric acid
and the flask we have
copper now the copper
as you for reasons you'll see in
a moment in the former a coil
account is the Morton a penny or tea
party piece because they're actually
made of steel
just a thin coating of copper
so gonna an old-fashioned penny
here this was made in there 1945
this actually made of solid copper
so we put one of these pennies
into the flask and we gonna do this
reaction in a sealed environment in a
sealed flask
any fumes that a pretty to be led away
through this cheap and absorbed in this
sodium hydroxide
for reasons that will
become apparent in a moment
okay so this is the
story although I Ramson
while reading a textbook of Chemistry
I came across the statement
nitric acid acts upon copper
I was getting tired reading such
absurd stuff and I determined
to see what this meant copper
was more or less familiar to me
for copper sense with that in use I'd
seen a bottle marked nitric acid
on a table in the doctor's office
well I was then doing time
I did not know its
peculiarities was getting on
likely to learn the spirit
of adventure was upon me
having nitric acid and
copper I had only to learn
what the word act upon meant
then the statement nitric
acid acts upon copper
would be something
more the mere words
all was still
interested knowledge
I was even willing to sacrifice one
of the few copper sense that in my
possession
I put one of them on the table
opened the bottle marked nitric acid
poured some of the liquid
on the copper a prepared
to make an observation so let's
at the nitric acid to the copper
and see what happens
I think you can say that quite a
vigorous reaction is taking place
to the green liquid
bubbling away
fumes are coming off I let's
continue with the story
but what was this wonderful
thing which I beheld
the saint was already changed
there was no small change either
a greenish blue liquid phoned
in fumed over the scent
and over the table the area in the
neighborhood of the performance became
colored dark red
a great cloud arose
this was disagreeable
and suffocating how
should I stop this
I tried to get rid of the
objectionable mess by picking it up
and throwing it out of the window
which I had meanwhile opened
I learned another
fact nitric acid
not only acts upon
copper but attacks
upon fingers
the pain led to another
unpremeditated experiment
I drew my fingers across my trousers
another fact was discovered
nitric acid acts upon tries as
taking everything
into consideration
that was probably the most
impressive experiment
and relatively probably the
most costly experiment
I never performed I tell
it even now with interest
it was a revelation to me it
resulted in a desire on my part
to learn more about that
remarkable kind a faction
plainly the only way
to learn about it
was to see its results
to experiment to work
in the laboratory so that the
reaction of nitric acid with copper
which produce these dark
brown fumes that you can see
and those fumes are
called nitrogen dioxide
and they are actually pretty unpleasant
which is why we're doing this in a SEO
apparatus
but nice and I oxide is a material that
can help us understand this question
about whether a chemical
reaction can go backwards
so in these cubes
we have equal amounts
all nitrogen dioxide
what I'm gonna do
is to take one of the tubes
and to place it in iced water
that it will cool down and the
other cheap a little place
in hot water to heat it up
so come back in a moment
and see if they're changed in any
way let's have a little look
at the chemistry that's
going on inside those tubes
and nitrogen dioxide
has a molecule
which consists of one at
Earth nitrogen and two atoms
oxygen if we have two molecules
nitrogen dioxide they can react
together to form one molecule
all another oxides of nitrogen
called dummy nitrogen
tetroxide that process
releases energy
when that extra nitrogen 19 bond
is formed it gives out energy
so that's like the ball rolling
downhill the ball rolling downhill
want the notion dioxide come together
performed I nitrogen tetroxide
but the domination tetroxide
can split up the molecule can
split in half if two molecules
of nitrogen dioxide
because for every molecule
diana ichton tetroxide we
get two molecules Nigerian
dioxide we have twice as many molecules
they can be arranged in many more ways
and that means the entropy
has increased so the
entropy tends to drive this
reaction from the right to the left
so these two effects the
ball rolling downhill effect
and the teenager bedroom effect a
driving this reaction is to love
opposite directions
what happens is that the reaction
actually goes in both directions
at the same time it
reaches a sort of balance
we call it an equilibrium where there
is some much in by upside present
and some dynamited and
tetroxide present and the
relative proportions that these
depends upon the temperature so if we
increase the temperature we put energy
into the system that's like pushing the
ball up hill
we go from right to left
if we cool system banned
then conversely we go from left
to right so that's the prediction
and we can test the prediction
because nineties and dioxide is this
dark brown gas that you see in the flask
here
but die nice in tetroxide
is colorless so we
go back to a cubes
this is the cheap that
was in the cold water
and you can see that
it's become a pale kala
this is the cheap that was in the hot
water I just put the side by side
you can see that heating up this
gas has made it dark brown and
contains more nitrogen
dioxide rest cooling it done
has made it at less
dark it contains more
die nitrogen tetroxide and
just two check of theory
what we can do is we can take
the hockey if the doc to you
and place it into the cold
war stop and then the
the coach you which is the pale
kala we can place that in hot water
will come back and have a look at those
in a moment we'll see if they swapped
places
the case that really brings us
towards the end of the lecture
want to do is just
to show you one more
curiosity and it concerns a
rather interesting and unusual
element and this
elements was
discovered in a mine
in a outside a little time court Turkey
which is near Stockholm in Sweden
and they have been extracting minerals
from the mine and they found a mineral
it seemed rather peculiar
they couldn't understand
what it contained insulate realize
that it contained a new element
this is so the beginning of the
eighteenth century and those that is if
you discovered a new element
you got to choose its name
and they decided to name the element
after the town to the turkey
this element is called yttrium
what rather interesting
is that this mineral contain
not just one new element
but they found out to
contain four developments
and so they decided to name all four
elements after the time to the turbine
so these four elements
accord yttrium
ytterbium erbium
and terbium which is a
a little bit confusing I think
we can look at the thirsty these
yttrium now yttrium
can be used to make a compound and I
have some at the compound here it's
called yttrium
barium copper oxide
that just a hard black
love ceramic material
when you to do is
to put into some
liquid nitrogen
and so that the tree in barium copper
oxide is now being cool down to minus a
hundred ninety-six degrees
but takes a moment or two to
cool down so while we're waiting
I also have in this cup another
piece of identical material
exactly the same as the first
and I'm gonna cover this
in liquid nitrogen
so that too can be cooling down
now at room temperature this
material isn't very remarkable
but when he gets officially cold has a
very interesting a very strange property
becomes what we call
a superconductor
now superconductor is a material that
is lost all its electrical resistance
and material which has 0
electrical resistance
has the property that it
can repel a magnetic field
so this rig the ring made of
steel and it's covered in little
magnets very strong magnets I alternates
North Pole South Pole North Pole and so
on
and in a minute when this is
cool down on we get to see
if thats yttrium
barium copper oxide
can repel the magnetic field
produced by these magnets
this just takes a a moment
or two to cool down
so we're looking here I can see
their boiling away very vigorously
that means the the ceramic materials
giving up its heats to the
liquid nitrogen is boiling
liquid nitrogen away
and and cooling down in the process
essentially I'm just waiting for the
boiling to stop
when it stops boiling that
means the ceramic material
has reached the same temperatures the
liquid nitrogen so limit minus a hundred
ninety-six degrees
okay so let's touch the Sun
then let's see if this can
repel magnetic field
okay so this is actually
quite a special kind of
superconductors what we call the type to
see picking up to and that means that as
well as repelling magnetic field you can
also track magnetic field remember I've
got
another wanna be sitting
inside this policy link-up and
underneath is a still at that
and on the top of the cylinder
is a very strong magnet now the
field from that night that
was already passing through
the ceramic material before
I added the liquid nitrogen
site now cool it down should
have become a superconductor
and hopefully it will have traps that
magnetic field so should still be
gripping onto that field
that means I should be able to take
away the support from this cylinder
by the way on the outside the cylinder
we've put the logo for the International
Year of Chemistry
2011 has been a year-long
celebration around the world
off with the likes of Chemistry and
the importance of Chemistry for
our everyday lives I thought it would
be a nice way to just mark the occasion
I think this is cool
down as sunday tea
see if I can lower
this very carefully
the
okay well thank you very much that that
pretty much brings us to the end of the
lecture
just before we wrap up I'm I thought
we would we finish with the
with a rather nice demo but
just before we do as 12
ask you to join me in thanking somebody
please put a lot of effort into helping
me prepare and
deliver this lecture
and thats crisp black stallion
okay just before we finish I thought we
take a look at this block of dry ice
if you remember we burn some magnesium
inside this block is dry ice
so the chemistry here was that the
magnesium reacted with carbon dioxide
to produce magnesium oxide and carbon
and if you look at the surface if this
we can see that it's coated in
a white powder and that's the
the magnesium oxide
if we dig down inside
the black had a is the
carbon and then finally
we swaps those two teams
that we put the dark to you
inside the iced water we put the
light-colored cheap in the hot water
we can say they have indeed
swapped places so the cheap
was dark has been cool
down has become lights
and the like quality has been heated up
it's become dark so we have the role
other
curious conclusion the chemical
reactions can go forwards
and backwards at the same time alright
well that really is the end of the
lecture
but I thought would have just one
more demonstration to finish
and I thought what
we do is two repeats
one of the earlier demonstrations
it's the demonstration
all the reaction between nitric
oxide and carbon by sulfide
I thought we did on a slightly
bigger scale so chris is bringing on
a cube of nitric oxide
some good add the carbon dice 05 began
chris is going to mix these together
once they thoroughly mixed
will set fire to the
end of the queue
all rights and
will put the light stand for
this might say thank you will
for coming we go old
its